y estonia letonia y lituania acordaron
restringir la entrada a su territorio de
ciudadanos rusos que viajan desde
belarús y rusia esta sería la primera
medida de su tipo en el bloque de los 27
la política general es así los titulares
de visa schengen con una serie de
excepciones me refiero a los ciudadanos
rusos no podrán cruzar la frontera pero
las excepciones por supuesto cubrirán
motivos humanitarios cubrir a los
conductores de camiones motivos
familiares diplomáticos pero se
publicarán respectivamente tan pronto
como los gobiernos lo decidan y habrá
suficiente tiempo de advertencia también
se espera que la prohibición de entrada
esté vigente a mediados de septiembre
luego de que los gobiernos nacionales de
los tres países bálticos la aprueben
formalmente
finlandia que también limita con rusia
no se unirá a esta iniciativa por
motivos legales ya que dicen no saber
aún si es posible aplicar esta medida
para los ciudadanos rusos con visa
schengen emitidas por otros países
europeos
esto se está convirtiendo también en un
tema de seguridad pública este es
también un tema de naturaleza moral y
política y creo que en este punto los
estados bálticos han llegado al acuerdo
y estamos ultimando detalles sobre la
política de restricción
estricto
en una medida para aumentar la presión
sobre el presidente ruso vladimir putin
el 6 de septiembre la unión europea ya
había avanzado en la suspensión del
acuerdo de facilitación de visas para
rusia de 2017 y suspendió el
reconocimiento de los pasaportes rusos
emitidos en partes ocupadas de ucrania